les usagers c'est ce courrier reçu par
certains salariés qui a mis le feu aux
poudres
une lettre dans laquelle la direction
signifie offrons deux ans qu'il serait
un abandon de poste et que cela pourrait
entraîner suspension de salaire et
mesures disciplinaires puis j'y vois en
papier réglable et la tension était à
son comble ce matin alors que hier les
échanges arbitré par l'inspecteur du
travail laissait entrevoir une issue au
conflit
on apprend ce matin que l'écho les
collègues des courriers
le coup de deux
de laver le droit de vote claires et que
si vous imposez pas le travail vous avez
des sanctions on attend des sanctions
d'une manière ou d'une autre
le conflit n'est pas terminé vous avez
bien vu qu'on allait quand même des
avancées on était en train d'avancer là
ils ont changé de méthode du côté de la
direction on annonce qu'après la levée
du droit de retrait le courrier envoyé
fait partie d'une procédure
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que l'alerté
a été levée par l'inspecteur et nous
appartenait à nos directions
d'interroger chacun des salariés sur
leur situation précise pour que en
définitive nous nous sachions et que
nous prenions nos responsabilités
vis-à-vis de notre personnel à la cft eu
la tension est à son comble les
discussions sont désormais un terreau
président directeur et par rapport à
mada élection interne atteint 6,9 à la
sauvage